[Music]
welcome my name is will torres i'm one
of the admission officers here at the
stanford graduate school of business
i'm so excited that you're here with us
today talking about
kind of preparing for a journey into the
world of technology and product
management
we're here to really talk about how to
use that
mba and the gsb experience specifically
um if you're thinking about launching
into a career in the technology or
product management space
and so to get us oriented to our
conversation today
uh we're gonna do a brief overview um
especially about what some of the career
outcomes look like
post mba we are going to get to know
our panelists and then from there i'll
have a few questions and we're really
going to open it up from there
uh the q and a box is again going to be
where you're going to be able to ask
your questions
if there is a question that you like i
encourage you
i encourage you to use that thumbs up
button that's going to upvote that
question and bring it to the top of the
list
you'll also see a quick survey going on
right now about
when you're thinking about applying uh
this is also helpful for us as we start
to think about what tips
best practices and words of wisdom we
might be able to share with you today
so as part of that overview
so when you come to stanford gsb the
world really does become your oyster
there is a career management center who
works with all of our students
um about a third of students get
opportunities through there
another third from faculty from alumni
as well as
our fellow classmates so there is no
shortage of places for folks
to find both full-time as well as
internship
opportunities during your time and
beyond about 91
of the class of 2020 um had job offers
within three months of graduation
and people had this sense of confidence
of being able to find something that
they were really interested
and that was meaning meaningful for them
i know i've had a number of
conversations about folks who said
you know what i have this job offer and
i know there's something better out
there for me
part of the stanford experience was
helping them build that confidence to
know that
yes something was out there and yes they
will find it and
kind of long story short they did about
71
of folks who come to stanford made that
made some kind of pivot whether it's
geography industry function um
and this is a question i often get if
you write something in your application
now
we don't hold you to that so if you're
interested in
tech but you end up in consulting that's
wonderful
coming to business school is about
expanding your horizons and seeing what
else is out there
if something speaks to you if you want
to explore that world and take that step
we are here to help you make that happen
and
now to give a little bit more light to
this process specifically
uh let's go ahead and meet our panelists
so tomer could you please tell us a
little bit about
what you're doing now and did you know
you wanted to go
into like the tech product space coming
into the gsb
yeah it's a great um introduction thanks
well so
hi everyone my name is tomer schwartz
i'm part of the class of 2018
um from here at the gsb i am currently
working as a product manager product
lead
at a tech called startup a series b
startup in san francisco called
rippling um to your question around
whether or not i
i knew i wanted to be in technology it's
a good question i think coming into the
gsb
i did i had worked in technology before
um
i had actually only worked in product
management for about six months prior to
the gsp
so you know i would say it was more of a
an educated hypothesis than like a firm
belief
um but definitely a bit of i had a bit
of a taste of it before prior to product
management
i i had done stuff around um
implementation
of customers and so i had seen different
parts
of what it'd be like to work at um tech
like
mostly enterprise b2b tech companies and
so heading into the gsb i knew it was
something that i wanted to
poke a little bit further on and see if
that was
gonna be the right thing post-graduation
and
at least so far it has it has seen that
way three years after graduation
yeah did you do much exploring during
your time at the gsb
yeah i did a bit of exploring i you know
i my undergraduate major
was in biochemistry and so um
i had always had a bit of of an edge to
see whether or not
life sciences would be a place where um
i could angle my way
uh and so that was the hypothesis coming
in um
and while i worked for my first years
out of undergrad at a
a tech firm focused on pharmaceutical
companies i spent a bit of time during
my
first year at the gsb i actually did
like a a part-time internship during the
winter
at a company working with actually mrna
which
since cova has become very hot um it was
less hot at the time and you know it was
it was a good hands-on experience seeing
i did some like strategy and biz ops
for them and ultimately i ended up
deciding
to kind of stick with tech though for my
my summer internships my first year i
did pursue sort of
both in a parallel track um but
ended up going more angling towards
tech i would say relatively quickly i
think by march and my first year i was
i'd become pretty confident that that
was going to be the likely route at
least
immediately post graduation yeah for
that winter
term internship was that part of a
program or uh was that something that
you kind of pursued independently like
how did how did you
go about that yeah it's a great question
so i said it's like it was ended up
being a little bit of both i'm trying to
remember where i found out about it
i believe it had been posted by either
one of my classmates through a friend of
a friend
or it was on like the careers of the
career website sort of like
routinely update stuff and it's the
stuff that they update is not
only for full-time or official
internship stuff some of it is a little
bit more
ad hoc so it was a resource that i used
pretty extensively throughout my time to
kind of see like hey every few days like
is there
is there something interesting it's it's
a fairly like low-cost effort to hop on
the website and see if there's
interesting stuff
of course i'd say pursuing a part-time
internship during school is is a major
like
decision just because of all the
different things vying for your time
when you're at the gsb which are awesome
and
you normally have to to trade stuff off
you can't do everything
despite our desire too so i think i
now that i think of it i probably found
out about it from that career website
and you already like started to go into
what i was about to ask you
how did you balance both that internship
plus like winter quarter of your mba one
year
didn't you still have like some of your
core requirements um like oh yeah
so i think i think winter quarter
freshen
uh freshman year for nba one year is
known as like one of the
more brutal academic quarters because
you're
usually finance is the uh the kind of
killer class
in that set um i yeah
it was it was it was not a i think the
internship i ended up devoting about
10 to 12 hours a week so it wasn't it
wasn't crazy but again it
it was up in in san francisco so i i was
taking you know wednesdays we normally
like don't have um classes at the gsp so
it was a good opportunity
to to head up to the to the city
and do like you know mostly a full day
in the office there and then i would
usually do
kind of like half a day either on
fridays or on mondays with whatever
worked out
it was it was not easy and there was a
lot of like
i would say jealousy seeing what other
classmates of mine were doing at the
time
um but i felt like it was it was still
worth uh investigating especially
prior to my internship my like
kind of full-time internship first year
so because i wanted to say like okay
i'm this seems like the right route it
doesn't seem like the right route in
this case
it didn't seem like the right route so
it was i think it was time well spent
yeah and then kind of sticking on this
theme of internships
so you did two internships in the summer
between your mba one and nba two-year
no no no i did so i did that one in the
winter i didn't do a ig
what we call like a gst i just did one i
did a
12-week internship at paypal during
between my first and second years
okay and then um there's a question here
about how early um
does recruiting start for project uh
management internships
um at some of the firms like do you have
any insight there because yeah
yeah so it really depends how big of a
company you're looking to intern at
so the general trend that you'll see is
that um the large companies that have
you know very
organized uh head count modeling
and recruiting processes are able to
kick off that process
actually like towards like the end of
november you start chit chatting
with them and seeing what's out there
and then um interviews
will actually begin around the middle of
january when you return from winter
break
heading into february that said i'd say
the majority
of of people that are looking to go into
tech
end up getting their internships in the
spring quarter which is between
april and in june and
that is usually it's usually at smaller
companies but even some of the larger
companies
kind of come through with with
opportunities
later on in the year so it depends there
um it's a i think one thing that's
that's helpful in coming in is sort of
having a hypothesis of whether or not
a large company is of interest a small
company is of interest
both um because that'll sort of define
the
the timeline that you end up taking yeah
and so like were recruiters coming to
campus where you
did you do some initial reach out or how
did you make some of these connections
or to learn about the opportunities yeah
it's a great question so you know i
started
with again like the the lowest friction
approach which is the career website
um so that was again the easiest or
easiest place to access i think it was
after the the sixth week uh
i can't even remember what it's called
but there's a bit of a moratorium
on on career stuff during the first six
weeks which is actually great
um to let people settle into academics
on campus
for your mba one year and then like
everything sort of like opens up
and so i recall you know checking out
the career website a bit
and then you know starting to develop my
own
my own list there are a bunch of other
resources if you're more focused on
you know smaller companies um if you're
focused on specific
niches within the tech sector tech can
stand for a lot of different things
um and then obviously you start kind of
poking at like alumni in the alumni
directory
um seeing what kind of random emails
come through
from classmates who used to work at
these companies you start doing
a lot a lot of coffee chats with nba
twos who are usually really like
nice and generous with their time so
it's so it's
it's a whole host of things and that's
kind of what i was getting at with like
time is at a premium for everything at
the gsb and so
um being a little bit thrifty with how
you spend it
is really critical yeah and then as
you're
thinking about so your journey and then
other friends
or folks that you know who um have gone
into the
tech space or the product management
space there's a question here
uh about um like do you have to have
a background in product management to
get an internship or a job after
or kind of how does that look like
that's a great question i think it's
it's a pretty common question that a lot
of my classmates came
in with as well and definitely a concern
because a lot of people come in with a
sort of an itch or a hypothesis saying
this product thing sounds interesting
i've done a
bit of research but can i get in um
you know i definitely have a lot of
classmates who do not have product
experience who are able to
to get into product um you know the way
that i
i usually look at it with product is
sort of like what strengths you can you
can play on and
um prior experience and background is a
facet but definitely not the only facet
um
so so other sort of pillars to think
about
when you when you're considering this
sort of um career would be you know
one like i think attention to detail is
critical
i think the ability to think
strategically
um especially as in future mba graduates
um is a huge one to to play up and
that's something that companies will
really be looking for
um being analytical so a lot of folks
that have like you know
consulting experience or finance
experience um
can sort of leverage that and play that
up in their interview another critical
facet that people are looking for when
it relates to product
is interpersonal skills like product
managers end up being in the middle
of a whole bunch of different functions
at their company
and for better or worse your key to
success is being able
to communicate with your other
team members who are not product
managers and sort of speaking their
languages
so um some of the what we call like soft
skills
that are very um that we focus on a lot
at the gsb
end up really helping with that so i
would say
as far as recruiting goes you have to
strategically like understand
what's what company you're you're
interviewing at who you're talking to
and what strengths you can you can play
up
um it won't be the same sort of script
or story that you can tell at every
company
it really will depend on like how you
can convince that like
you have the right skill set um to to
bring to them and
given the specific team that you're
interviewing at the specific industry
that the company is at but you
definitely will have
both like from your pre gsb experience
and usb experience
a bunch of tools in your toolkit to to
talk about during the interview process
even if you don't have um more classic
like i was a pm
prior to the gsb yeah um perfect segue
let's talk about some of these tools
i know on one side there are some of
like the hard skills and then you just
you mentioned some of the softer skills
interpersonal
um kind of elements that are so critical
to your work
uh can you tell me can you tell me a
little bit about like any classes
let's start with like the soft skill
side like the interpersonal like any
that stood out to you
um and why of course i mean i think
for the very like we joke about this as
as gsp graduates but like the class that
you will often hear about
is is colloquially called touchy-feely
or interpersonal dynamics
um and you know i think for me was it
was a class that i heard about
coming free prior to coming to the gsb
and it definitely did not disappoint
um it's this really interesting um
experiential
class where you spend the majority of
your time rather than
like in a lecture setting you end up
spending it with
what's called like a t group which is um
a group of
of 12 of your club you plus 11 of your
classmates plus a facilitator
and you you go through a bunch of call
it an
interpersonal journey for a quarter
um and that one's really critical i
think for understanding
how other people perceive you how
different things that you end up
saying really um touch other people
even if you don't necessarily mean them
and then
kind of if you want to think about it
more about like how do i get my job done
it's also how you can influence people
ultimately
like a lot of this stuff is about
especially when it comes to product
it's around influence like how can you
influence people
to believe in the the problems that
you're trying to prioritize as a pro
as a product manager and so that class
touch you feel your interpersonal
dynamics is definitely um
a critical one i think you know there
are a few other classes that i think are
mentioned less often around soft skills
so for example one is called
like acting with power um which is a
really fun one
where you you literally like
act um it is it is a very real like
acting which uh for me it was not
a a point of comfort
acting not something i had background in
but it was a really fun
you know unique g like experience that
you can only achieve
in school i think it's very difficult to
replicate elsewhere in the workplace
and we we actually like would have
scripts
it's scripts slash like academic
materials explaining how different
tactics
um cause people to perceive us in
different ways and it sounds very like
ego maniacal but
um it it can go a long way when you're
in different
um sort of situations in the workplace
so those are some of the softer ones i
will do on the transition to
some more tangible things oh no i
actually have a couple more questions
i think this is like a fascinating uh
track of conversation like
talking about like how you show up in a
space and how you exert influence
um there are a couple questions here
about and i'm sure this is going to be a
recurring question that comes up over
our conversation but from either
touchy-feely
acting with power or any of the other
classes maybe even
leadership labs where
like have there been any instances where
you've been implementing some of the
things you've learned in there and like
how has that like affected the way that
you operate in the working place
oh all the time i mean especially like
you know for i always joke for better
worse like in in product like
i i have no i have not had a moment
where i could be like
alone in a room just doing stuff which
means that everything is interpersonal
right everything is about
um how people are reacting
to the ideas that i'm bringing forth how
i'm reacting
to to their input and collaboration and
so for me you know
a few of the examples that i think about
are you know we learn about
when to use emotion for example and how
to express
like different levels of emotion and how
someone can be like
even keeled for the majority of their
of their time as when you know them all
of a sudden when they you know
engage in extreme emotion you really pay
attention to that because it's so
different than their like standard
status quo
and so that's a tactic that i've used a
few times at work to really get a point
across it's not something that i would
choose to abuse but is one that i
remember
when i went through it was kind of like
a an aha
finding moment from uh from touchy feely
that
you know people gave me feedback um that
said like
i was really surprised when when you act
that way it really
um made me pay attention and it was
something that was
uh not something that i did on purpose
in in touchy feely because it was it
happened to be like a very um
involuntary
reaction to something that happened
there but was a really powerful
learning and then you know the other one
is around how to
like that i would talk about is around
how to show
kind of like use vulnerability um
to to get people to understand you
better and to
to trust you so i think that's a that
was one of
again um a huge lesson from these
classes around like
we i think that the kind of i call it
cheap learning is to
to never show um cracks in the armor
right
to never um waiver from like a
strong like determined person who knows
what they're doing but actually there
are there are many times where
showing just like a little bit of
vulnerability or a lot of vulnerability
if it's with the right
with the right audience or the right
people who
um like that's what it takes to get them
on board can be incredibly powerful
the tricky thing is that it doesn't work
for on everyone
and it doesn't work at the right time
which is
one of the the frustrating learnings
from the class like it's it's not a
perfect playbook
um it's there's a lot of like kind of
try
and learn and try and learn and but but
these have definitely been like
important things for me
as i've gone back into the world the
last three years
to to get my points across and be a
successful product manager
yeah i love how that comes back to what
you're talking about earlier about like
getting the tools you need to succeed
it's like here's the tool and then like
in that try and iterate and kind of
workshopping it over the course of your
career you're just like continuing to
sharpen and
kind of fine-tune those tools to the
settings that you need it for
there's a lot of fine-tuning sometimes
you miss a little bit but there's a lot
of fine tuning
yeah that's part of the process too
right like how do we embrace
quote-unquote failure or as like
opportunities to learn like
growth mindset um that spirit of
feedback
feedback is a gift absolutely yeah that
uh feedback is the gift of something
that you you hear a lot at the gsb
and i think is something that can
can be not not fun to take um both of
the juice being in the real world but it
is
a really powerful um was
a really powerful takeaway and
i think something that i still sort of
will as you said like
workshop and tinker with and decide how
to
to really take in um and it is helpful
to to not be defensive about feedback
that comes in and that was a big
for me personally at least like a big
learning at the when i during my time
here
yeah i mean it's a learning that like
i'm still trying to process even in the
working world
which is like oh i feel something let's
unpack that
exactly um let's switch over to the hard
skills i know we talked a lot about like
the
like the personal development how you
show up in a space how you influence
kind of what are also like some of the
technical hard skills that you find
um are helpful in your job kind of
whether it's in
product itself or just kind of in the
tech world writ large
because i know there are also some
questions here about okay what are
other opportunities in the world of tech
beyond um
beyond product management yeah
definitely i mean so a few classes that
come to mind
for me the areas that we're so i was a
biochem major so for me like
academically a lot of the stuff was new
so
there were a few like marketing classes
for example that i found to be helpful
so one that comes to mind is
a class called consumer behavior i you
know i
we really focused on i would i wouldn't
call them tricks
but you know actual like tactics
and strategies to to get consumers to
better and like
go towards your desired outcome let's
put it that way
um and so i think you know that one in
particular is important if you're
thinking about going to
a b2c company like where your main user
will be a consumer but it is still
helpful
even for me at a company like rippling
where i work today that is
is b2b where most of my customers are
business customers but it's uh small
businesses so they tend to act like
consumers
and so when i think about things like
visual design and how we talk to them
um i definitely think of some of the
lessons from that class honestly like
my intro to marketing class around
things like segmentation and positioning
and targeting
was really critical like i didn't have
any background in that i definitely came
from the mindset that like
marketing was some voodoo art that
didn't have a lot of
you know actual um
like discipline to it and so that has
been really helpful and thinking about
how you
like for me at least as a product
manager like how i focus on my customers
how i
segment them who like my target customer
is
how i can make sure that when i when i'm
building something or i'm prioritizing
something
i'm really really focused on what i've
refined
as the the target segment and not just
trying to like
peanut butter to an entire like market
because that's impossible to solve and
so that has been very important
and then you know there there's a lot of
like i
have never taken an accounting class to
be honest and i actually
you know some people say oh accounting
it's boring it's this and that i think
it's really critical
um like a really critical foundation for
anyone who's gonna end up being a leader
in business even if you're not gonna be
an accountant and i don't think anyone
in my class really went
deep into like specializing in
accounting but
it's a really critical course skill to
understand um
you know profit and loss statement in in
in
cash flows and things of that nature
makes you much
more like able to talk when you when
you're in a room with other folks maybe
finance folks
that are trying to make decisions around
how to allocate
head count to your team and you're like
i want to go toe-to-toe with you and
make sure that i get the proper head
count that i need
like you're able to do that a lot more
than someone who's just like
i'm only a product manager and just like
put the heads on my team of people
like so actually having like a detailed
numbers-based conversation
is incredibly helpful and then lastly i
mean some other
classes that were very specific not very
specific but ended up really helping in
product
are so one is startup garage um you know
startup garage sort of employs like
design thinking um to
how you refine like a a problem and then
eventually think through a hypothesis
and
uh point of view statement and a
solution which
you know even though startup garage sort
of sounds like something that you would
do
if you want to go only into
entrepreneurship
that's actually like not quite correct
like the
um the frameworks that are taught there
i use pretty routinely
um in product because we really try
in product to think about you know agile
development
and hypothesis based development and so
this
type of a class really forces you to go
through the rigor
of refining a problem asking a bajillion
questions doing really good customer
discovery
before you ever think about a solution
and so like that one
i actually don't think was properly
advertised i remember when going through
it
as like oh this will help you if you
want to go into product it was sort of
like
hey people that are thinking about
entrepreneurship like go
here and looking back on it that one was
really helpful
the last one that i talked about is
called um aligning startups with their
market
um we actually don't know if it's still
being offered but was
was really helpful and again even though
it aligning startups with their markets
sounds like it's really focused on
entrepreneurship it can be
leveraged for basically any new product
initiative
even if it's a larger company in my
opinion and so again really focused on
on customer discovery and how you
you know you pivot how you judge when
you
may have reached product market fit how
you think about scaling in
so those are a few of the classes that
come to mind there are
obviously a bunch of other ones that i
found to be helpful
yeah i love all of the like translatable
learnings the frameworks and like
not just entrepreneurship as a career
path but also as a way of thinking that
is like applicable
to so many different spaces exactly
and then so you've been at a
large firm you've been at a small firm
like you've seen a breadth of different
kind of roles that someone can go into
into tech
especially thinking about the mba and
the skill sets that you develop
like what are some other roles within
the tech world that you've seen like
some of your classmates go into
yeah so um there there are a bunch of
different roles so
one of the more common ones that i've
seen
you know is business ops which is
depending on the company it's sort of
like an internal consultant at a tech
company
um a second one would be product
marketing management pmm
um very very common to go into
um and then there's sort of a whole host
of
other more refined things at smaller
companies
or larger companies to call them
different stuff so
so they they run the gamut right like
you can be on the the non-development
side of the house and still definitely
be
in um in in the tech world
having come from an mba right you can
deploy
um more strategic skills purely or you
can be
um on the product side so i've seen
people go into a variety of roles
there that's one of the in my opinion
that's one of the the beauties
of um kind of a general management mba
it purposely makes you
very malleable one of the frustrating
things about it could be that it doesn't
set you on like a super narrow path
so i think that's a really important
consideration for folks
who are thinking about a full-time
general management mba to know like
you know it sort of like opens up a lot
of a lot of doors but it
will force you to do a lot of um
research and testing to see like which
of the the many opportunities are right
for you
yeah and then pivoting right like post
graduation
that's probably not going to be your
career for the rest of your life
and so how do you set up like for the
skills to thrive elsewhere
um because you you've already pivoted
right from largest
that's right yeah and you know i i think
for me actually one of the main
sort of like the last push for me to end
up
actually applying for an mba it was
because i had gone to a point
at so i worked with a company called
zenith prior to the gsb
and you know i had been there for a year
i had done some other stuff at a
different company but i had been there
for a year
felt like i was was doing really well
folks really appreciating my work
and i decided that i wanted to switch to
a different team internally actually
wanted to switch from implementation to
product marketing
and so you know i went through a pretty
disorganized internal process it was a
small company there was no like
official process you know i spoke with
the person who was
was running that team and she ended up
giving me like a little
case exercise that i saw and she's like
okay great we'd love to have you join
and you know eventually what happened
was and i was like that's amazing i'm so
excited about this new opportunity
because i was tired of where
i was working i wanted to learn new
skills and i ended up um
for a certain amount of time getting
blocked and the thing that
they they told me was like you're doing
well where you are you're doing very
well where you are
we need you here and you know for me
personally i was at a point where i was
like
no i want to to do this
um and that was actually the the thing
that in
that prompted me to apply for an mba i
ended up seeing an mba
as a way to make sure that my career was
was future proof that does not
necessarily be like
super super successful day one high
flying but it does give you
the skills to have a really like
fascinating and dynamic career
for in my opinion for decades like it
gives you the general skills
to be able to pivot and not um pigeon
hole yourself and so
for me that like with the the point that
i was at there i was like no i don't
want to be
be told that this is the the appropriate
path for you like i want to set out on
my own paths
um but i want to make sure that i have
kind of the the toolkit to do that
and so for me like that mba experience
was it was a part of that gearing up
that's helpful i know i get asked all
the time from people like how do you
know what's the right time
or even like i don't know
if i need an mba to be successful or
thrive
in in x y or z field so like why go
right and so you've been thinking about
the long game
i think that's a super good question
yeah so you know for me i thought about
it as a long game i think it's a really
i think it's a really good question
right like for a lot of folks they're
like i'm
kicking butt at my current place like
i'm good
like i don't need i don't need an out
and you know thinking back to a lot of
my classmates like
that's where they were they were doing
incredibly well and they still
um decided to take that time and the way
that i well it's funny you know
when i when i was applying i went
actually to gsb
admission session and the um director of
admissions
at the time um derek sort of said this
thing which again you you kind of
you take with a great assault because of
course you know he's trying to recruit
people but
he said it it's never gonna be truly
feel comfortable and never truly gonna
feel like the right time to go it's
always going to be a bit of an
uncomfortable decision and if it is
uncomfortable
a slightly uncomfortable decision it's
probably the right time
um and for some reason that actually
really resonated with me it's like
when if you wait until the point where
you feel like you've stagnated in your
career and then you need it
you probably waited just like a little
bit too long
which i get is that it's like a very
uncomfortable feeling obviously an mba
is
not the right thing for for everyone at
all but
i find it hard to believe that you'll be
at a point where you're like this is the
perfect point for me to go now right
like
there's always a reason why not there's
always a reason to go elsewhere so you
really have to ask yourself like
why would i go what's the value that i
would get what am i trading off and have
like a really
serious conversation with with yourself
and your and your stakeholders
around in your life around like when i
put everything down
on a paper or my mental checklist or
however you make decisions like is this
right but i don't
it'll never be like uh like a binary
obvious decision like
duh like that was the right time that
was the right school
uh i think it's difficult to get to that
sort of clarity at least for me
yeah so let's sit down with your younger
self and have that conversation
i didn't you probably didn't think
you're going to be having this
conversation saying safe
from a question from annie about like
what is the value what was the value add
for you
after six months so now that you're
thinking like
younger you you from a you know pre
and mba where like putting that decision
like
how am i gonna think about it's worth to
you today
six months or just afterwards like how
would you articulate that to your
younger self to like
help them like come to a decision
yeah it's a good question i think the
way that i look at it
now it kind of it goes back to that at
least for me
i had always seen my mba
as a long-term investment in my future
self so it was not something that i
expected that
the day after graduation would be this
like
oh my gosh i turned the page and like
everything is different
um and it's one of those things at least
for me where
i see i see the lessons in like
small bits throughout my liking back to
the last three years like consistently
throughout the last three years
um and i anticipate that i will keep
seeing that as time goes on and so like
a part of it definitely like it did help
me um
get to the job at a larger company that
i was interested in pursuing
right after the gsb so that's kind of
like a very tangible thing that it
did um but i think more importantly what
it enabled me to do
is is to have that flexibility to be
able to be in
a variety of different situations that i
you
it's hard to anticipate being in and be
like i
did sort of going through a laboratory
um that helped prepare me for that or
you know i did have a classmate who
worked in that industry
or i did have like this really rich
conversation with someone
about this particular problem that they
had and now i'm going through it or
um i need to form a partnership
for work and hey this other gsp
is on the other side so like you sort of
see the value
in like a variety of different ways ways
throughout
nice and then there's a question here so
actually multiple questions around like
hey
i'm going to distill it and this is
these are questions from ryan
and ade and jinsu about ginseng about
you know we talked a little bit about
classes but
for folks who are like thinking about
pivoting or exploring what are some
opportunities
and resources that can help you get at
least a little bit of expert
like experience in that world um and
kind of get your feet wet
i i assume that they're asking while at
the gsp because obviously like
some people so i think it was i i can
think of a few things and then you know
so some of my classmates for example
decided to take
um classes what we call across the
street which is outside of the gsb and
others stand for classes so some people
decided to take classes at the
design school for example some people
took classes in the computer science
department
god bless them um you know
that there are a whole bunch of things
that that being at a school like
stanford allows you to do so that's one
i think the second thing is doing
like a part-time during the year
internship um
which again is is a sacrifice and a
trade-off but hey
part of being in product is all about
trade-offs and so like
way to practice that in in real life so
you know i think that's incredibly
helpful i think going to
really like tapping into the alumni
network is
critical from day one and it's a lot of
work like
you know networking some people love
networking other people despise
networking
um but no matter how you look at it it's
incredibly time consuming i think it's
rewarding and fun
but like is really time consuming and so
being able to
spend a bunch of your time having
conversations with people and dif people
in different industries
different company sizes because one of
the the beauties and frustrating things
about product is that when you ask
people what a product manager
does it the answer will
range from a to z especially if you ask
people different companies
and so it's actually really important to
to be able to do the research to
understand like
okay is this someone who's doing more
strategy are they spending like 80
of their time with just engineering and
design are they more on the go to market
side
like um you know and how does that fit
my strengths and my desires
and how can i use that to refine my
career
search better so that i can achieve both
like my desired outcomes but
what i'm capable of doing given my prior
background
um so i would do a combo of those right
like talk to alumni
um you know outside of classes talk to a
bunch of your classmates a lot of my
classmates actually
sort of that we joke at the gc that
everyone has like a side hustle
so a lot of people try to start even
outside of like startup garage like
they had little things that they were
trying out and and hey like that's the
way to both like
have real world like experience um but
also to beef up your resume a bit
so you know and the other thing that
folks did especially when they were
trying to transition is
they did either like incredibly low paid
or unpaid internships which
at smaller companies to at least get a
sense
of what product would be like they had
no experience um and
you can do that while you're in school
it's not as big of a sacrifice as
obviously doing something unpaid
post post-graduation which is a really
big
decision and investment yeah
i'm gonna go back to something you said
a little bit earlier about like spending
a lot of time and energy
in networking um and how some people
like thrive in it and
others it's a little bit more effort um
having gone through that process
yourself and kind of
lessons learned along the way for those
of us who find it a little bit more
draining like
any tips or inspiration or words of
encouragement that you have
um help us think about like what is
networking how can we apply
especially in the tech space i would
think about it i i would try
to you know some people approach number
three as like
i i so i would say quality is better
than quantity
right so if you if you're thinking about
networking it's like
if i have 50 con 5-0 conversations and
they're each like
boom boom boom boom boom like kind of 15
minutes very focused like i'm sure
i'll get something out of them i'm like
yeah you might
it sounds really painful like you have
to be a very particular sort of person
to do that i would focus
on on quality so having pr like
doing spending more time doing more
research
but having less conversations actually
like would be my advice
um for the majority of the time to like
invest in a conversation really go deep
with someone who's a proper fit but then
obviously like yeah
part of it is sure like it's a numbers
game but that i would
more tailor towards keep an eye
like have quick conversations with
classmates even if
y'all aren't best friends or you don't
necessarily see like
um the right path but like choose where
you're investing the time
choose which alumni you're reaching out
to like don't like
run yourself dry like if you i think
networking will be a lot less
painful if you're having conversations
with with people that you truly find to
be like valuable
and interesting um i don't think it'll
be you know 100
of the time sometimes it's like yeah
it's a bit of work and it's a grind but
i think if most of the networking that
you do is stuff that you find to be
interesting which which will probably
mean just like less conversations
you're gonna be like okay like that was
maybe it took me a little bit to click
send on that email maybe it took me a
little bit to like
get out of the house to go to like koopa
in the middle of campus
even though i was like oh god i really
don't want to do the awkward coffee
meet-up
um but otherwise like i feel like once
you sit down and have the conversation
it's it's really rewarding and i guess
now in the world of cohort it will
probably be via zoom
but you got my point yeah
um here's the question from sophia that
has a number of upvotes
what surprised you about the pm role or
experience coming out of the gsb
and like we talked a little bit about
actually a lot about like
how the gsb sets you up for success but
yeah any surprises yeah i mean
so at least for me right the role that i
took after the gsb was
was a paypal which you know is not
massive like google but it's it's quite
large
um and one of the it was not a
total shocker because again like i
interned there but
one uh like the just the sheer amount of
time that i
i spent sort of like
convincing people of stuff rather than
solving a problem um or
actually building things that was a bit
of a surprise
um and a bit of a disappointment and i
think
it might have been a function of the
particular team that i
i went on which was more of like a a
newer team
at a big company which was really
exciting for me actually but then i
think looking back on it it meant that
it was a lot of like
trying to get people on board with
really like
unbaked ideas um and so for me a
learning from that was okay i should try
to
like i get a lot of energy out of seeing
impact
uh which i don't think is like a rare
thing but at least for me like that
that has like a very concrete positive
reinforcing cycle
and so that was one of the reasons why i
decided to go
to my current company to rippling which
was which is
and was a lot smaller um but fast
growing and like
you can it is much easier for me to see
the impact that my work is doing
technically
in the same role as a product manager
which like day in
and day out i am able to to ship little
things
um and or big things and see
how our customers are using them see the
pleasure or pain
that they're bringing customers and i
for me like that's a huge huge huge like
positive reinforcing so like
i'm like oh i want more of that uh i
will work harder
whereas when i at least for me when as a
people i just spent
a ton of time doing powerpoint
presentations
which i knew was going to be a part of
the role i did not anticipate that it
would
consume that proportion of like as
high of a proportion of my time as it
did yeah and it sounds like uh
in any presentation um some of those
soft skills interpersonal dynamics
learnings acting with power probably
came in really handy
absolutely yes yeah so that was helpful
i was able to navigate it while i just
had gotten to a point where i said
okay but do i want to spend 80 like do i
want to spend 20
of my time um kind of talking in between
teams and doing presentations or do i
want to spend 80
of my time and so at least for me like
that decision to move to ripping at
least at this very like
fine-tuned stage in my career i was like
okay i want to shift it like i
i'm very realistic i understand that
um inner dynamics at work are critical
to succeed like that's one of my
learnings from usb
um but i would prefer to
optimize for less of my time being spent
that
that way yeah um and here's
a question from david that i really this
is the first time i've heard this
question
i really appreciate it because we talk a
lot about like
spirit of collaboration community um
but david wants to know like what
opportunities are available for gsb
students interested in tech or product
to connect and or work on projects
together
like we talk a lot about like supporting
each other but on a more tactical side
like
like does it happen yeah it's okay so
i mean it definitely happened so you
know like immediately when you ask that
question startup garage comes to mind
right like that's a very like
tangible way like the the point of the
way that startup garage works is that
you end up forming teams of four to five
people
and you propose like a
high level problem statement and you
form these teams and so
that's probably one of the more like
concrete ways
um that the gsp facilitates that that
said
there are a bunch of like ad hoc ways
that people end up
sort of collaborating uh there are also
things like
you know there are things like career
groups your first year where peop where
you get put together and you have a
facilitator from the cmc
um where you talk about this sort of
stuff so
i say that there's there's more like
tactical hands-on things and actually
like you know a lot of your classes end
up having group-based projects which is
a
a a double-edged sword um but but a good
learning
it's so it'll sort of depend right like
if if
i saw a bunch of folks from my class who
ended up
either starting side hustles and or real
companies together throughout their
times
at the gsp some of them are still
working on these companies and
most of them were not startup barrage it
was like
hey i'm interested in this i'm
interested in this hey like we either
have the same background
or we have um complementary backgrounds
like
let's try to like work on this together
or
what we joke about the classic like try
to recruit a cs student
to work with you um i saw a little bit
of that trying to happen but hopefully
we can
dispel those those stereotypes i think
geospheres can can do their own work
without recruiting uh
poor cs undergrads but there is a lot of
interaction with other parts
absolutely right absolutely the
different um
d-school courses i was going to say
these school courses there's also like
um biodesign is a good one
where you they end up bringing folks
from like the engineering school
and i think from the d school and from
the gsb so
i saw that kind of manifest itself in a
few different ways
yeah there's a number of
interdisciplinary courses that folks can
take it or like like you said
taking classes from other departments on
campus great way to like broaden your
horizons both intellectually and like
network-wise as well
absolutely all right and so i'm gonna be
selfish and take this last question
um i'm curious um
we actually haven't talked about the
application much at all
um and even though you don't know and
you probably never will know why
you were admitted even though you are
pretty awesome and i
loved spending this like last 55 minutes
with you
um if you could give yourself
a younger self any advice about the
application process
um what would you tell yourself
yeah so i mean as you said i think one
of the things that i i joke about is
like after people get into the gsp
they have all these like fancy theories
about what they got and no one knows why
they got in unless you like
tapped into the admissions office's
files so
i think for me though what i would say
is that
um what i what i would tell myself
looking back at the process
is to try to enjoy it which sounds
really tongue-in-cheek
um but it is a rare time especially when
you are
um like at least for me i was like heads
down
and working working a full-time job as i
assume like the vast majority of the
folks on this
on this call are or having like a life
in your personal life
um and i remember at the time when i was
applying i was like oh my gosh i have to
think about what matters most to me and
why you have got to be kidding me
um but it really forces you to have a
unique like retrospective
um like moment about about yourself and
like
why is it that you're looking to invest
two years
of your life and not an insignificant
amount of money
in a in a in a program and so like
it's a rare opportunity to be able to be
introspective where there's so many
other things happening around you in
life and
um it's it can be if if you do spend the
time
really going deep and thinking about
like okay why is this the right time for
me
what do i want to get out of this like
why is it that i think it'll be helpful
what do i want to do after it's just
like it is an incredibly like rewarding
introspective thing like
probably probably like even if you don't
get in and i
i remember um there's the gsp grad from
2016
who was telling me this what i was
applying and i i do remember being like
yeah easy for you to say because you got
in and she was like an nba 2 at the time
um but it's really i don't know it's
really
true and and like the other thing that i
would say is
no one else can like come up with the
right answer for you
because the combination
of of things around like why it's the
right time what you want to do with
it why you like it you can't
like it just it has to be that answer
has to come from
investing the time and thinking about
all those questions and the story will
inevitably be like uniquely for yourself
so i i would tell myself to like
enjoy the process despite it being like
in
rightfully incredibly stressful
thank you so much for your wisdom
sharing your experiences
speaking of the application next week we
are holding a series of events
um themed application week where we are
actually going to go
into all different facets of like
telling your story what does your story
mean in a business school application
context and what are ways to start it
how do you put pens and paper how do you
convey it to people over
kind of speaking and we also have a
number of different panels with
admission officers
about the parts of the application how
do we use it
what are ways that you can think about
you know understanding
your who you are in our process and how
to put your best foot forward
and if you haven't done so already i
encourage you to
start a mystanford.mba dashboard with a
few questions there
we'll help consolidate and put together
things that might be of most interest to
you
so with that thank you again tomorrow i
had
a lot of fun um i can't wait to see you
on campus
hopefully in the near future um
everybody who joined us thank you for
sharing your time with us
um have a great rest of your day and
stay safe
[Music]